now to receive these callbacks we first
go back to the physics engine class and
add a nice wrapper function that allows
us to set some of our callback functions
for box 2d in general box 2d allows you
to get callbacks during multiple phases
of collision we have a begin contact
which occurs when things are touching
but the collision calculation hasn't
done yet and contact when the contact
analysis is over and post solve which is
called once the physics collisions have
occurred for our purposes we need to
find a new function in the physics
engine that allows the engine to pass in
custom callbacks to be executed when any
one of these phases occurs this code is
fairly simple although deep we take in
an object that contains callbacks we're
looking for and define logic that will
issue a callback to those functions once
the engine hits that face so for
instance we assume that if the callback
stop post solved method exists then we
define the post solve method on our
listener as a function that takes in the
contact and impulse pass from box2d and
will actually send that to the post
solve function in our contact giving it
the two bodies for the fixtures that are
touching now box2d operates in a
different environment that we do that is
that it operates in fixtures that are
colliding and we have to go then fetch
the body object that we're using once
we've set all of our callback handlers
that we want we actually can call world
dot set contact listener and pass in the
listener object this will effectively
bake in all of our contact objects into
the world so that anytime we get these
collision objects will get collision
callbacks